name's maximum Barty and I've been an
agent for ten goddamn years you want to
know what it's like let me tell you
about the low bar details
[Music]
huh it's funny I always tell my boys
don't give your life for the foundation
make some other best to give this But
Here I am [ __ ] hypocrite that's what
I am but nobody ever promised me
retirement so that's okay
a figure I got another 10 minutes before
they make it through the door
closest backup is 50 miles away and I
know bonds ain't gonna make it to him in
time a bonds if you still listening you
better make it you [ __ ] [ __ ] you
hear me this place is gonna blow pretty
soon there are plenty of safety
protocols in one of these plants but I'm
an engineer I know exactly the wrong
things to do and in one order I don't
know just when but it'll take out a good
chunk of the countryside when it does
wait till after before you come in the
right time for anyone to come get me
nobody's getting out of your life by
visiting to say about it got one last
bullet and damned if I'm gonna wasted on
those [ __ ] so I don't know who else
can hear me [ __ ] broke the receiver
but as far as I can tell the transmitter
is still good so I want to say something
to the rest of you we are the ones who
saved the world not the doctors not the
council no one else us
we're the last line of defense the only
line remember that don't die for the
foundation don't fight for the
foundation fight for the six billion
folks who won't wake up tomorrow if you
don't that's worth dying for some old
fart wants to play with skips he can go
[ __ ] himself
you ain't machines you ain't in soldiers
your people men and women who do the
[ __ ] nobody else could do and people
make a choice
there's a damn big difference between
doing the job because you were told to
and doing it because it's got to be done
I don't care if it's the same [ __ ]
job it is a goddamn difference there's
got to be
or else what the hell are we fighting
for and I want you to remember each and
every one of you you ain't alone you
understand none of us are ever alone we
got each other every agent that's alive
is there to watch your back no matter
what happens you're one of us it doesn't
matter if you're a saint or an [ __ ]
you're family you got hundreds of
brothers and sisters right there on the
ship with you ready to pull you out and
when you're alone you're still not alone
if your agent who came before everyone
who's coming after you they are with you
everyone who you ever train with
everyone who's watched your back or
bitched to you at meals is with you you
carry them with you so you remember the
you ain't alone you pass that on to
everyone you meet when we die we deserve
to know that we ain't alone no matter
what happens we've got each other
oh and one last thing a proudiy if we
have a work together no matter what else
I said to you I'm proud of you even if I
never laid eyes on you just for doing
the job I'm proud of you
it's been an honor guys and when you
come in if this don't finish him off
give them hell for max Lombardi
[Music]
yeah my birthday
[Music]
your world
Oh
what
[Music]
well back
[Music]
ow
[Applause]
[Music]